BRINGS POELTLio: HE FELT KELDON
JOHNSON'S ELBOW IN HIS BACK AND
RELEASE.
>> Ryan: HARDEN.
FOUL AGAINST ATLANTA, AND
CLAXTON IS I JUST
PAST THE MIDWAY POINT.
OHFOUL.
>> Stan: THIS IS HOW
TIMING.
AGAIN, DON'T EVEN HAVE TO
DISCUSS IT.
DOING A LOT OF THAT.
BUT A TURNOVER.
THERE G
MILLSAP, BIG FINISH!
PAUL MILLSAP IN THE FINISH.
IT STARTED WITH A
WINDMILL, DUNK.
[ LAUGHTER ] UTAH TRYING TO THE
BRISSETT DONE IT AGAIN.
>> PACERS HAVE THEAW IT ON MOND
WEDNESDAY, SAW THETRAMPOLINE.
>> Michael: YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
GOING TO A GOOD THROW.E
DEFENDS AND AS TOUGH AS HE IS.
>> Stan:
A LOSS.
>> Eric: THAT MAY BE THE
>> Dell: IT IS OKAY TO SMILE
WHEN YOU DO STUFF LIKE THAT. GA.
CAUGHT A BODY INTENDED.
[ LAUGHTER ] A
SHOW.
YOU DON'T WANT THAT HAPPENING
THE FOUL.AS A SPARTAN.
ZACH RANDOLPH AS A SPARTAN.